this is your first uh Olympiad uh Magnus
how is uh your individual result uh well
it's not my first olympi actually okay
well there there you go sorry Agnes
tomorrow you're moving on to play the
young Notre Beck of duur of a world
rapid Champion how excited do you get
for matches like that against players
who potential World Championship level
Talent he was champion in 2021 and I
took it back in 2022
you're right I'm sorry uh about move 19
uh it looked like you touched one piece
and moved another uh could you just
explain what
happened I mean not this again uh this
happens in every single world
championship match like clearly some
pieces are adjusted and um and it's with
no intent to to move so do better